pc grand theft auto trilogy owners can
now get a game for free halo infinite's
winter event is live and more
rockstar is offering players who bought
grand theft auto the trilogy the
definitive edition a free game following
the backlash and negative feedback that
the collection has received players who
purchased the pc version of the game
through the rockstar games launcher will
have the option to claim one of the
following games grand theft auto 5
premium edition grand theft auto 4
complete edition max payne 3 la noir or
bully scholarship edition for players
uninterested in any of these titles they
can opt to claim a great white shark
card in gta online or 55 gold bars in
red dead online the deadline for this
offer is january 6 2022 at 12 a.m
eastern time
halo infinite's next multiplayer event
winter contingency is now live developer
343 industries revealed in its latest
blog post that the event will run from
december 21st 2021 to january 4th 2022.
rewards for winter contingency include
armor pieces and armor attachment
holiday themed coatings for your spartan
and weapons along with a free nameplate
emblems and a special backdrop halo
infinite's other event fracture tinrai
will return early next year and will
include some major improvements one of
those tweaks will be a more impressive
set of armor as the gear that was
originally on offer looked a lot less
impressive than the halo cosmetics that
were for sale for the free event
but that's not all for the winter themed
adventures and some of our favorite
games nvidia has launched a huge new
winter wonderland themed minecraft world
showing off the potential of minecraft
with rtx while also raising money for
the great ormond street hospital
children's charity the world can be
downloaded for free as long as players
have the latest version of minecraft for
windows installed the nvidia rtx winter
wonder world makes use of minecraft with
rcx which nvidia has launched just over
a year ago the new holiday themed world
takes plenty of opportunities to show
off just how gorgeous ray chasing looks
even with minecraft's block-based
graphical style the world consists of
three huge snow globes each containing
its own unique setting one a winter
wonderland one as santa's village and
the third as a winter setting all three
combined make up a virtual area of 38
acres and took minecraft builder ushio
takura over 300 hours to build the world
contains interactive elements including
roller coasters an ice skating lake and
a petting zoo as well as a handful of
playable storylines and quests the
world's charity tie-in can be found in
its full-size recreation of the grand
ormond street hospital building where
players can find a qr code to donate to
the hospital's charity
which themed event are you looking to
get into this week and why let me know
in the comments and be sure to leave a
like and subscribe so you don't miss
your next episode of gamespot news and
so much more
[Music]
you